si la définition de l'austérité c'est
une baisse des dépenses c'est
probablement ce qui est en train de
passer ou ce qui va se passer en 2015
2016 dans le budget qui était présentée
aujourd'hui par carlos météo dans les
secteurs de la santé et de l'éducation
on ne prévoit qu'il ya trois ans des
dépenses en santé de 1,4 pour cent si on
enlève l'inflation eh bien on tombe à
zéro pour cent d'augmentation et en
éducation 0,2 pour cent d'augmentation
seulement pour comprendre et que si en
prenant compte de l'inflation at on
encore de l'inflation une réduction des
dépenses du gouvernement le secteur de
l'éducation se fait une éternité qu'on
n'a pas vu une chose pareille que des
croissance des dépenses aussi faible
dans des secteurs aussi importants
en retour le gouvernement est très
optimiste sur la croissance économique
prévoit 2 % croissance du produit
intérieur brut cette année en raison du
gouvernement d'un investissement des
entreprises sur plus fort et de la
consommation des ménages également qui
sera plus forte
le gouvernement peut dire merci à la
chute des prix de l'essence qui amène
plus d'argent dans les poches des
contribuables même si les gens trouvent
que le prix de l'essence baisse pas
assez et merci aussi à la chute des taux
d'intérêt qui permet au gouvernement de
revoir en baisse d'à peu près 300 à 400
millions de dollars
ces prévisions de paiement en intérêts
sur sa dette pour mes prochaines années
les surplus vont commencer et sondés
dans le fond déjà commencé parce que
vous savez si on exclut le fonds des
générations et les provision de 400
millions que le gouvernement veut se
mettre de côté à partir de l'an prochain
c'est de deux à trois milliards de
dollars de surplus par année on peut
prévoir dans la réalité pour le
gouvernement du québec si son plan match
fonctionne griffures je termine
rapidement quelques annonces l'abolition
de la taxe santé ça s'en vient
le crédit d'impôt pour solidarité ne
sera plus versée à tous les mois pour
tous les bénéficiaires on bonifie des
crédits d'impôts dans les jeux vidéo
dans la culture notamment
on prévoit la stratégie maritime sera
bientôt annoncée dans les prochaines
semaines et on annonce également des
baisses
les entreprises et les pme mois